so wehrte zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
wir machen einen harten themen schnitt
der bundestag hat noch weitere themen an
diesem sitzungstag an diesem mittwoch
auf seiner tagesordnung stehen es geht
jetzt um ein zukunftszentrum dass die
bundesregierung errichten möchte die
idee geht auf die empfehlung der
kommission 30 jahre friedliche
revolution und deutsche einheit zurück
die in der letzten legislatur getagt hat
und mit dieser neuen institution will
die bundesregierung vor allem die
erfahrung der ostdeutschen mit wandel
und umbrüchen würdigen wir hören in die
debatte ein und
weiteres erfüllen wir dann bei den
nächsten redner erster jetzt am
rednerpult ist bernhard hermann für
bündnis 90 die grünen
mutige frauen und männer in der ddr
friedlich gegen die sed-diktatur
aufgelehnt haben
wir haben uns getraut und haben
widerstand in einer diktatur geleistet
unser wunsch nach freiheit demokratie
und selbstbestimmung war ungebrochen
als die im jahr 2020 unser jubiläum
feierten blendeten wir viel aus zb den
bereits seit jahren andauernden krieg in
der ost ukraine
wir ahnten nicht welche konsequenzen das
haben würde auch für uns
werden sich viele menschen im westlichen
teil unseres landes infolge der
wiedervereinigung kaum etwas verändern
mussten außer überspitzt gesagt ein paar
zahlen auf dem lohnzettel durch den soli
den ja alle zeiten wurden im anderen
teil unseres landes ganze leben auf den
kopf gestellt
während die einen wie gewohnt in ihrem
sommerurlaub fuhren
wurden die anderen über nacht arbeitslos
während die einen in ihrem gewohnten
umfeld wohnen blieben als wäre nichts
gewesen mussten die anderen ihre
familien verlassen und arbeit in anderen
teilen der republik suchen
von einem tag auf den anderen mussten
ostdeutsche sich aber in einem völlig
fremden system zurechtfinden
sicherlich all das geschah aufgrund des
wunsches nach freiheit und
selbstbestimmung
doch solche um brüche gehen auch an
einem nach freiheit strebenden menschen
nicht spurlos vorbei
mit diesen schilderungen geht es mir
nicht ausdrücklich nicht darum wunden
und gräben zwischen ost und west
aufzureißen sondern gegenseitiges
verständnis zu schaffen
auch wenn die transformation seit der
wiedervereinigung eine gesamtdeutsche
aufgabe ist die starken politischen
wirtschaftlichen und gesellschaftlichen
einschnitte trugen die menschen in
ostdeutschland
den westdeutschen blieben sie
überwiegend unbekannt
und wenn wir also von transformation
sprechen sollten wir immer beachten dass
dahinter ganz konkrete biografien ganz
reale menschen mit beachtlichen
lebensleistungen stehen das
zukunftszentrum
kann mit einer wissenschaftlichen und
kulturellen aufarbeitung im dialog dies
aufzeigen und den gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt stärken
werden wir in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten den blick stark nach innen
richten
und eine deutsche betrachtung des
transformationsprozesses einnahmen
klammerten vieler die historische
europäische perspektive aus dabei gab es
bereits in den 70er und 80er jahren in
polen in ungarn der cssr und auch der
ddr zivilgesellschaftliche bestrebungen
nach demokratischer selbstbestimmung und
der wahrung der menschenrechte
doch nicht nur das wissen hierzulande
viele nicht
möglicherweise waren fehlendes wissen
oder die fehlende sensibilität die
gründe auch dafür dass die man dann
proteste in der ukraine ende 2013 anfang
2014 bei vielen schnell in vergessenheit
gerieten
unsere erinnerungskultur bot für die
demokratischen bestrebungen in ost und
mitteleuropa
weder vor dem zerfall der sowjetunion
nach danach jenseits von sonntagsreden
viel platz und das trotz durchaus
ähnliche erfahrungen zumindest der
ostdeutschen
die frage nach dem warum müssen wir uns
alle stellen
und zu machen uns die ereignisse in der
ukraine und der seit dem 4 sie ist ein
februar andauernde angriffskrieg
russlands den blick nicht nur auf uns
selbst zu richten vielmehr sollten wir
den betrachtung stars auf die
transformation in europa erweitern
so kann ich persönlich den
unterzeichnern des offenen briefes mit
über 95 wissenschaftlerinnen an der
stelle gut verstehen denn und die
transformation der neunziger jahre zu
verstehen und einzuordnen muss deren
vorgeschichte seit den 1970 er jahren
ebenso einbezogen werden
wie ihr gesamteuropäische rahmen
das zukunftszentrum sollte als
brückenbauer zwischen ost und west
europa fungieren um die geschichte der
postkommunistischen
regionen nicht nur in deutschland
sondern in westeuropa bekannter zu
machen und den einsatz der
zivilgesellschaft für demokratie in
diesen ländern zu würdigen denn eine
nationale betrachtung der geschichte
greift zu kurz und nur wenn wir
gegenseitiges verständnis auch an dieser
stelle aufbringen kann europa
zusammenwachsen
[Applaus]
nach mehr als drei jahrzehnten im
vereinigten deutschland ist es wichtig
dass unser land weiterhin
mit unserem nachbarn eng
zusammenarbeitet wir gemeinsam die
demokratie in deutschland und auch in
ganz europa stärken nun geht es darum
den standort in den ländern brandenburg
sachsen mecklenburg-vorpommern
sachsen-anhalt oder thüringen in einem
standortwettbewerb auszuloten und die
gestaltung des zentrums zügig und
transparent mit einem gesamteuropäischen
blick auf die geschichte deutschlands
und ost und mitteleuropas voranzubringen
eine breite gesellschaftliche debatte
zur stärkung des profils des zukunfts
zentrums wäre sehr wünschenswert
ich bin davon überzeugt dass das
zukunftszentrum als begegnungsort einen
wichtigen beitrag zum diskurs zwischen
wissenschaft kultur und
zivilgesellschaft leisten wird und so
für die folgen der transformation
erfahrungen deutschlands und seiner
macht band gegenseitiges verständnis
schaffen und den europäischen
zusammenhalt fördern wird vielen dank
bernard herrmann für die grünen hat hier
die debatte eröffnet also ein
zukunftszentrum für deutsche einheit
europäische transformation das haben die
ampel parteien bereits in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag
aufgenommen die initiative von dieser
kommission die in der letzten legislatur
gearbeitet hat jetzt geht es auch noch
darum wo soll das zukunftszentrum stehen
ihr worden mack war es jetzt für die
unionsfraktion
feierte die kreise regierung der ddr in
ost-berlin
pompös den vierzigsten jahrestag der
staatsgründung
an diesem tag gingen in plauen in meiner
heimat rund 15.000 mutige menschen auf
die straße und sie protestierten
gemeinsam gegen die zustände im land
jörg schneider ein ehemaliger
wehrpflichtiger bei den grenztruppen hat
zuvor heimlich flugblätter verteilt und
zu dieser demonstration aufgerufen
wie von geisterhand setzte sich damals
ohne erkennbare führung der
demonstrationszug in bewegung
erste sprechchöre wurden laut die ersten
transparente für reformen reisefreiheit
und frieden erschienen die staatsmacht
setzte wasserwerfer ein doch ist lang
doch es gelang nicht die menge
aufzulösen
das war der beginn der großdemonstration
in der ddr der wille zur veränderung und
das verlangen nach freiheit waren
stärker als die angst vorm
sicherheitsapparat vor maschinenpistolen
und wasserwerfern in blauen namens
unmittelbarer friedliche revolution
ihren anfang
ohne diese friedliche revolution hätte
es die deutsche einheit nicht gegeben
die wiedervereinigung liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ist das große deutsche
glücks ereignis unserer jüngeren
geschichte
aus wir sind das volk wurde auch damals
schnell wir sind ein volk und es folgten
beispielslose transformations-
entwicklungen in den neuen bundesländern
ebenso wie in allen ländern mittel und
osteuropas
schmerzhaft waren sie gleichwohl sie
haben narben hinterlassen
aber wenn man heute durch unsere städte
und gemeinden geht sieht man auch was
alles entstanden und gelungen ist
und auch die europäische einheit meine
damen und herren ist damit fest
verbunden ein weiterer großer glücksfall
auch und gerade für uns deutsche
meine fraktion
unterstützt die gute idee eines zentrums
für europäische transformation und
deutsche einheit
diese wurde von der kommission 30 jahre
friedliche revolution der letzten
bundesregierung erarbeitet wir danken
allen mitgliedern für die arbeit und wir
begrüßen auch das erarbeitete konzept
welches auf drei säulen fußt
wissenschaft kultur sowie dialog und
begegnung
die staatlichen wirtschaftlichen und die
gesellschaftliche veränderungen seit
1989 und 1990 und ihre auswirkungen auf
die menschen sind bisher sehr wenig biss
systematisch erforscht und aus diesen
erfahrungen und mit dem europäischen
klick können wir für die kommenden
transformationen auch wertvolle schlüsse
ziehen wir sollten heute schon
definieren wie wir diese
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse für
nachfolgende generationen nutzbar machen
wie finden sie ihren weg in die
schulbücher zum beispiel
für ebenso wichtig halte ich das
geplante vorhaben neue formate des
gesprächs zwischen bürgerschaft
fachleuten und entscheidungsträgerinnen
und entscheidungsträger zu finden wir
müssen reden trifft ist ziemlich gut
es besteht immer deutscher und
grenzüberschreitende gesprächsbedarf
immer noch und immer wieder und dem
sollten wir raum geben
jetzt gibt es eine vielzahl von guten
ideen bewerbungen und vor allem gibt es
eine breite debatte die sehen wir aber
noch am beginn wir plädieren also dafür
jetzt auch nicht zu überstürzen uns eher
ein paar monate mehr zeit zu nehmen und
die fenster und türen der diskussion
weit offen zu halten
natürlich dann mit einem ergebnis mit
einem ergebnis zum standort und vor
allem aber zum konzept
der deutsche bundestag wir als
abgeordnete
sollten dabei ein sehr zentraler akteur
sein
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
müssen uns unbedingt mit einem impuls
aus der zivilgesellschaft getragen unter
anderem auch von fünf ehemaligen
kommissionsmitgliedern befassen sie
fordern ich zitiere eine
weiterentwicklung zu einem europäischen
freiheits und zukunftszentrum dass die
politisch und kulturellen bedürfnisse
bündnisse zwischen der deutschen
zivilgesellschaft und den europäischen
nachbarn stärkt um gemeinsam freiheit
und demokratie gegen autoritäre
herrschaft zu verteidigen
im angesichts der aggressiv
imperialistischen politik des
autokratischen putin russlands spricht
da vieles dafür dies einzubinden und wir
haben auch schon vorbilder
und es gibt auch schon vorbilder in den
euro regionen beispielsweise in der
euro-region grenze da haben bayern
sachsen und thüringen und tschechien
gemein gemeinsam schon viel erfahrung
mit großen wie kleinen
grenzüberschreitenden projekten und an
dieser nahtstelle zwischen
mittelosteuropa ost und westdeutschland
werden
transformationsprozesse gemeinsam erlebt
und bewältigt und diese gilt es
wissenschaftlich mehr zu nutzen zum
schluss lieber herr präsident
auch die weiteren guten empfehlungen der
regierungskommission sollten umgesetzt
werden beispielsweise das angedachte
ostdeutsche
begabtenförderungswerk nun liebe
bundesregierung lieber carsten schneider
seid ihr gefragt und gefordert vielen
dank
sagte yvonne amag was hier für die
unionsfraktion das zukunftszentrum soll
in ostdeutschland stehen soll noch eine
standortentscheidung geben und
beispielsweise aus sachsen aus dem
bundesland ausgeben mag was kommt hat
sich plauen zusammen mit leipzig
beworben jetzt der ostbeauftragte der
bundesregierung carsten schneider
staatsminister im kanzleramt hat vor 14
tagen die eckpunkte vorgelegt
kollegen meine damen und herren den
bildschirm liebe kolleginnen mag was
vielen dank für ihre rede auch kollegen
und kollegen die noch folgen gesprochen
haben auch für die unterstützung für
dieses zentrum dieses zentrum für
deutsche einheit und europäische
transformation es ist wie bereits
ausgeführt wurde ein auftrag aus der
regierung der einheits kommission 30
jahre deutsche einheit die wir vor zwei
jahren hat die leiter ins bonner weist
die begegnung betrifft zwischen ost und
west zwischen nord und süd aber auch
groß und kleinstädten oder auch leuten
die vor 1990 geboren worden leuten die
nach 1990 geboren wurden diese begegnung
haben maximal an der bültstraße
stattfinden können das ist bedauerlich
weil es zeit gewissen wäre auch nach
diesen aufregenden spannen umwelt in den
30 jahren mal kurz innezuhalten sie
fragen was es mit unserer gesellschaft
gemacht hat und ob wir eng beieinander
sind oder ob wir uns vielleicht mental
auseinander bewegen und bewegt haben
oder ob wir zwischen land stadt und land
die unterschiede größer sind als sie
zwischen ost und west sind als spannende
fragen die in diesen zukunftsbezogenen
werden sollen wie auch die frage der
transformation das klingt ja so
technisch also die komplette umwälzung
einer gesellschaft von der totalen
sicherheit im sinne von dann
arbeitsplätze sicher dann dein leben
wird gesteuert zu du kannst alles selbst
in die hand nehmen und bist frei
diese freiheit von oder freiheit führt
für viele in erfüllung gegangen ich
verwende 14 mal kann ich da sagen für
meine familie ich kenne aber auch andere
bei denen das nicht der fall war und was
wir lesen zentrum machen wollen ist für
einen bieter interesse füreinander auch
zu wecken also für die unterschiedlichen
begegnung zwischen ost und west und kann
nur sagen dass ich meiner zeit in erfurt
wir hatten den ersten austausch mit
einem katholischen mädchengymnasium
limburg erinnere mich da noch sehr
gespannt daran als wir dann da heißt
14-jährige plattenbau kinder darauf
schlugen das war dass das war ein
kulturschock darüber stattgefunden hat
aber es war ein spannender oder etwas
sanfter soviel kann ich verraten und
meine kollegen meine freunde von damals
wissen auch genau was ich meine dies hat
natürlich weniger in den letzten jahren
stattgefunden um ehrlich zu sein und ich
finde dass dies nicht nur notwendig ist
sondern dass es eine gesellschaft
ausmacht zu reflektieren und eben auch
neugierig zu bleiben
wir starten diese standortwettbewerb so
wie sie ihn uns beauftragt haben vielen
dank für diese unterstützung für staaten
in ergebnisoffen und auch ortschaften
das ganz klar zu sagen die kriterien die
wir anlegen sind die die die eine
kommission noch die letzte
bundesregierung in ihrem beschluss im
juni gefasst hat und die sie auch in
ihrem antrag des bundestages
wiederfinden und ich möchte sie auch
herzlich einladen dass auch wir die
diese entscheidung in einer durch auch
eine konsultation mit den fraktionen in
einer jury treffen in der ich zum
beispiel dass mich auch klar sagen kein
stimmrecht haben möchte weil ich
nicht möchte dass das so aussieht als
sei das tv geben sondern ist offen und
ich bin wirklich sehr begeistert wie
viele städte in ostdeutschland ich hatte
gelegenheit im blauen frau kollegin
machbar ist mir das anzugucken jena ich
meine anlagen von frankfurt oder ich
komme demnach
die dann auch die kommission das aber
das interesse da ist das ist diesen
bundespolitische leuchtturm geben soll
zweiter punkt den ich hier aber noch
ansprechen will ist nicht nur dass wir
eine nabelschau ost und west machen
sondern dass wir den europäischen blick
mit in den also den blick in den blick
nehmen ist super deutsche ausdruck den
ich ja gerade kreiert haben also das
wird heute unter den europäischen blick
weiten und deswegen habe ich meine erste
reise in meiner funktion das
dienstreisen ins ausland auch nach prag
gemacht ganz bewusst und ich kann nicht
sagen dass die tschechische regierung
auch klar gesagt hat sie wollen sich an
diesem projekt mit beteiligen sich mit
einbringen und ich werde juni nach
mit ihrer unterstützung auch nach polen
reisen um auch dort dafür zu werben dass
wir die mittel osteuropäischen länder
als bestandteil der neuen europäischen
union aber eben auch als frühere
bestandteil der anderen seite des
eisernen vorhangs
für ostdeutsche sehr froh und dankbar
sind das ist in polen mit der
solidarnosc bewegung auch in ungarn aber
auch in prag mit der botschaft dass es
dort die bewegung hin zur freiheit gab
die uns die möglichkeit gegeben hat die
mauer auf einzustürzen
und zu oft habe ich das will ich selbst
würde ich sagen den blick nach westen
gerichtet das meint gar nicht komplett
sondern paris london washington als
politische aktion und zu wenig und zu
selten nach venus
bukarester oder prag und ich finde dass
uns das gut ansteht als bundesrepublik
deutschland und ich lade sie hat sich
dazu einen finger
lassen schneider war das der
ostbeauftragte der bundesregierung er
hat eckpunkte vorgelegt für die
errichtung eines zukunftszentrum für die
deutsche einheit und europäische
transformation und parallel dazu gibt es
von den koalitionsfraktionen einen
entsprechenden antrag das ist beides die
grundlage der heutigen debatte
meine damen und herren um es vorweg zu
nehmen unser problem mit dem zukunfts
zentrum für europäische transformation
und deutsche einheit ist nicht dass die
lebensleistung der ostdeutschen
gewürdigt und wissenschaftlich erforscht
werden soll dass ausstellungen und
bürgerdialoge dazu stattfinden wir sind
die letzten die das nicht unterstützen
würden unser problem ist dass dieser
aspekt immer weiter in den hintergrund
tritt zugunsten der sogenannten
europäischen transformation auf den
letzten metern haben sie auch den titel
geändert die deutsche einheit steht ihr
es nur noch an zweiter stelle und das
lässt tief blicken sie versuchen hier
das historische narrativ zu etablieren
die friedliche revolution und die
deutsche einheit seien quasi nichts
anderes gewesen als eine art
durchgangsstadium zu einem und
vielfältigen europa aber die bürger der
ehemaligen ddr meine damen und herren
sind 89 auf die straße gegangen unter
einsatz ihres lebens für ihre freiheit
in einem geeinten und souveränen
deutschland und nicht dafür dass unsere
souveränität an einen europäischen
superstaat mit sitz in brüssel
verscherbelt wird
ihr antrag spricht ja nur sehr abstrakt
und verwaschen von transformation der
klartext findet sich in den vorschlägen
der so genannten konferenz zur zukunft
europas die das eu parlament in seiner
letzten sitzungswoche quasi unter
ausschluss der öffentlichkeit
verabschiedet hat was kommt da alles auf
uns zu eine gemeinsame europäische armee
vereinheitlichte steuerpolitik
verschärfte sanktionsmöglichkeiten gegen
einzelne mitgliedstaaten aufgabe des
einstimmigkeitsprinzips sowie
gesamteuropäische volksabstimmungen mit
anderen worten die südstaaten südländer
werden demnächst mit ihrer mehrheit über
die zahlungsverpflichtungen deutschlands
entscheiden und ganz wichtig ihr
lieblingsprojekt umsetzung einer
gemeinsamen und kollektiven
migrationspolitik inklusive aufklärung
von kindern ab beginn der grundschule
über migration und integration
meine damen und herren ein
amerikanischer bundesstaat wird mehr
nationale souveränität besitzen als
deutschland nach diesen reformen wir
werden zu einer tribut pflichtigen
corinths brüssel statt gestuft und sie
alle die demokratisch sich demokratisch
nennen den parteien haben dem in
straßburg zugestimmt das ist das
gegenteil von demokratisch denn ohne das
deutsche staats volk als souverän hört
die demokratie zu in exten deutschland
zu existieren auf das sollten sie dem
volk zumindest auch offen sagen und vor
diesem hintergrund weist all die
plakative bürgerbeteiligung in der
zukunftskonferenz wir jetzt auch in dem
zukunftszentrum doch einen deutlich
deutlichen alibi charakter auf man kann
sich des eindrucks einer demokratie
simulation nicht erwehren zumal sie ja
vor allem die sogenannte
zivilgesellschaft einbeziehen wollen als
regierungs konforme angels die sich
selbst mit steuern bevor sich heran
gezogen haben und wenn wir dann noch
lesen im abschlussbericht der kommission
30 jahre deutsche einheit es gebe ich
zitiere noch immer ein signifikant
höheres niveau an rassismus fremden und
ausländerfeindlichkeit in ostdeutschland
daher soll es sich das zu gründende
zukunftszentrum der frage nach den
bedingungen weltoffener und damit
zukunftsfähige verhältnisse in
ostdeutschland mit besonderer
dringlichkeit vor dringlichkeit wittmann
in großen lettern geschrieben
dann wird doch die arrogante attitüde
offenbar die sie den ostdeutschen in
wahrheit immer noch entgegen bringen
nehmen sie endlich zur kenntnis dass man
in dresden oder rostock keine
verhältnisse wie in frankfurt
bahnhofsviertel oder in duisburg marxloh
haben will das ist absolut legitim und
es ist infam das als rassismus zu
diffamieren da hin und her ich komme zum
schluss wir stimmen dennoch nicht gegen
ein zukunftszentrum für deutsche einheit
sondern wir werden uns enthalten vor
allem wegen der positiven potenziale
wenn sie es ernst machen wirklich mit
der ostmitteleuropäischen vernetzung und
wirklich vertreter der mehrheitsmeinung
aus polen etwa aus ungarn zu wort kommen
lassen dann könnte es sogar manche
verwirrung in sachen migration oder
europäische zentrale sierung hierzulande
heinzler korrigiert werden vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollegium
als nächster redner hält das wort der
kollege thomas hacker fdp fraktion
thomas tacke für jeden liberalen er
sitzt im ausschuss für kultur und medien
der herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir kommen zurück zum thema die
bilder prägten sich ein
am 27 juni 89 durchschnitten der
aussenminister ungarns bühne horn und
sein österreichischer kollege alois mock
bei sopron den grenzzaun zwischen beiden
ländern der erste zaun zwischen ost und
west öffnete sich die grenzen im herzen
europas folgten die mauer wurde
eingedrückt der eiserne vorhang war
vergangenheit das waren die sichtbaren
zeichen einer bewegung der menschen
ihres kampfes für freiheit und
demokratie die friedliche revolution
erfasste die ddr die samtene die
tschechoslowakei und die singende das
baltikum die in polen losgetreten wellen
setzte sich fort und erfassten die
menschen in der sowjetunion in den
ländern des warschauer pakts bis
weiterhin die bulgarische
schwarzmeerküste mit einer
unvergleichlichen dynamik die freiheit
hatte gesiegt als sozialistisch
geprägten gesellschaften entstanden
marktwirtschaftlich orientierte
demokratie aus den gelebten utopien des
real existierenden sozialismus wurden
mit einem schlag transformations-
gesellschaften in denen die menschen
ihren platz 9 finden mussten der
systemwechsel darauf die menschen
unvorbereitet und mit allen konsequenzen
für ihr leben ihr berufliches und vor
allem ihr privates leben ja es gab
gesellschaftliche brüche die bis heute
nicht geheilt sind und große
enttäuschungen die bis heute nicht
überwunden sind das lässt sich nicht
beschönigen und auch nicht leugnen und
doch ostdeutsche städte und gemeinden
haben sich zur boom regionen mit hoher
wirtschaftsdynamik hervorragende
lebensqualität einer exzellenten
hochschullandschaft und großer
innovationskraft entwickelt
zukunftsweisende unternehmen
zukunftsweisende unternehmen schafft
neue arbeitsplätze gerade auch in
letzter zeit heute ist der
lebensstandard der menschen in
ostdeutschland deutlich gewachsen
natürlich gibt es weiter aufholbedarf so
unvorbereitet der systemwechsel kam die
danach gemachten erfahrungen bei uns und
unseren nachbarn scheint vieles
gemeinsam zu haben von diesen
erfahrungen lernen ist der weg den wir
mit dem kunz zentrum für europäische
transformation und deutsche einheit
bestreiten wollen mit diesem
zukunftszentrum bekommen eine
einrichtung einen thinktank von
gesamteuropäischer bedeutung eine
bedeutung die das europäische zentrum
der solidarischen danzig bereits hat es
erinnert an die geschichte und behauptet
sich auch in zeiten
nationalkonservativen gegenwinds und
ihren gegenwind ertragen wir auch es
arbeitet für unsere gemeinsame
europäische identität ist man dann die
bedeutung von frieden demokratie und
freiheit und daran werden wir auch sie
immer erinnern heute ist das wichtiger
denn je das gemeinsame ist das zentrale
element dass das zukunftszentrum künftig
in den mittelpunkt stellen soll wir
wünschen uns dass die erfahrungen zu
vieler menschen die glücklich nun die
bitteren die lebensleistung in eine
größere würdigung erfahren damit
gesellschaftliche brüche gehalt und
enttäuschungen überwunden werden wir
wollen dass das zukunftszentrum ein ort
wird der breit getragen wird und zeigt
dass die deutsche einheit immer ein teil
einer europäischen einigung war daran
wollen wir arbeiten gemeinsam für die
menschen in deutschland in europa danke
[Applaus]
thomas hacker war das für die fdp und
wir hören jetzt gesine lötzsch für die
linke die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende
vielen dank herr präsident meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren ich bin eine
große freundin der wissenschaft doch was
untersucht werden soll in diesem zentrum
das kann in jeder ostdeutsche auf der
straße erzielen wenn sie untersuchen
wollen warum viele menschen in
ostdeutschland die deutsche einheit als
fremdgesteuert wahrnehmen schauen sie
doch einfach mal wer in den chefetagen
in ostdeutschland und in der
bundesregierung sitzt dort kann man die
ostdeutschen mit der lupe suchen und das
ist zu viele fremde stimmung ist oder
nicht sicher der trend an das war eine
industrie vernichtungs maschine sie hat
den maximal möglichen schaden verursacht
sie hatten hat ostdeutschland die
industrialisiert und die abwicklung von
die abwicklung von wirtschaft
wissenschaft sport und kultur haben in
ostdeutschland dauerhaften schaden
angerichtet und darüber müssen wir reden
meine damen und herren auf unsere
nachfrage
hat die bundesregierung berichtet dass
von 1998
bis heute 90 prozent aller öffentlichen
bibliotheken und nahezu zwei drittel der
theater in ostdeutschland geschlossen
wurden ebenso teilt es sich mit den
kinos und selbst jedes zweite orchester
im osten ist mittlerweile spurlos
verschwunden und das ist der falsche weg
meine damen und herren
darum müssen ist oft richtige
schlussfolgerung sein wir müssen endlich
wirksame dinge für die menschen in
ostdeutschland tun wir müssen verhindern
dass ein großer teil der ostdeutschen
rentner in altersarmut verfolgt tun sie
etwas damit die menschen ihre mieter und
die heizkosten bezahlen können und wenn
wir den gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
stärken wollen dann reicht ein
zukunftszentrum nicht aus sondern wir
brauchen in jeder stadt ein kulturhaus
und einen öffentlichen sportplatz meine
damen und herren und kommunen fehlen
über
159 milliarden euro an investitionen hat
uns die kfw kreditanstalt für
wiederaufbau vorgerechnet allein für
schulen fehlen über 45 milliarden euro
also müssen wir hier mehr geld
reinstecken denn in schulen und
universitäten wird gelehrt und geforscht
und dort sollen jugendliche die
demokratie jeden tag erleben können
meine damen und herren und vor allem das
ist die feste überzeugung der linken
sollen die jugendlichen lernen dass
krieg kein mittel der politik mehr sein
darf und dass aufrüstung keinen frieden
sichern meine damen und herren eine
europäische zukunft werden wir haben
wenn wir sie gemeinsam friedlich
gestalten und das ist unser
grundanliegen vielen dank
gesine lötzsch für die linke war das ja
das zentrum soll zumindest nach dem
eckpunktepapier drei aufgaben haben
forschung zu den umbrüchen nach der
vereinigung ausstellungen die auch die
leistung beispielsweise der ostdeutschen
würdigen sowie ein raum für begegnung
und
veranstaltung aber inhaltlich gefüllt
werden noch detaillierter soll das ganze
eher auch es geht natürlich nicht nur um
die standortauswahl um einen wettbewerb
der städte nächste rednerin katrin budde
für die spd
präsident meine damen und herren wenn
sie bei facebook werbung bekommen mit
der frage sind sie 1965 geboren oder
früher und dann das angebot für ein
super kleines leistungsfähiges hörgerät
kommt oder wenn sie beim eintrag des
geburtsjahres im formular so lange
zurück scrollen müssen dass es schon
denken kommt das noch dann wissen sie
sie haben schon ein ganz schönes stück
lebenszeit hinter sich gebracht bei mir
ist das jedenfalls so und ich sage für
mich es war eine gute lebenszeit bis
hierher eine lebenszeit in zwei staaten
die unterschiedlicher nicht sein könnten
ich war teil einer friedlichen
revolution ich habe die spd eine freie
demokratische partei in meiner region
mit gegründet und aufgebaut ich war teil
des aufbaus eines bundeslandes ich habe
struktur brüche gesehen und
strukturwandel gestaltet als
landespolitikerin als landesministerin
zum teil erfolgreich aber oft noch bin
ich auch gegen wände gerannt ich habe
als junge diplom ingenieurin erlebt wie
mir schlechter qualifizierte
erwachsenenbildner aus dem westen etwas
beibringen wollten und wie haupt
technologen rosa ostdeutscher betriebe
den kopf eingezogen haben weil sie nicht
wussten was im neuen system sagen dürfen
ich habe miterlebt wie meine eltern ende
50 aus dem berufsleben ausscheiden
mussten und ihr leben komplett neu
sortieren mussten und ich habe gejubelt
typen von mckinsey und spd vittel erlebt
die noch nie einen betrieb von innen
gesehen hatten wir uns aber erzählen
wollten wie man die betriebe
umstrukturiert und ich habe auch
miterlebt wie für gestaltungswillen wie
viel mut und kraft in einer gesellschaft
steckt trotzdem der alltag ihrer
menschen von einem tag auf den anderen
komplett anders war
was aber mein persönliches leben
beschreibt ist dass ich immer teil der
war die gestaltet haben für viele
menschen in ostdeutschland und osteuropa
war und ist das anders sie waren und
sind teil eines prozesses aber mit weit
weniger aktiven gestaltungs und
entscheidungsmöglichkeiten wir wissen
heute dass die zeit nach 1990 nur sehr
wenig mit strukturwandel dafür aber umso
mehr mit struktur brüchen zu tun hatte
das war in ostdeutschland zu aber wir
wurden durch das vereinte wiedervereinte
deutschland in einem gemeinsamen system
nicht nur sozial aufgefangen sondern für
uns gab es eine besondere bessere
situation und trotzdem behaupte ich dass
auch heute noch in den tiefen der weiter
westlich liegenden deutschen
bundesländer sehr viel nicht klar ist
wie groß der bruch 1990 war das eher
gesellschaftlich viel viel tiefer ging
als vermutet wird und daraus auch ein
teil der deutsch-deutschen
missverständnisse resultieren
das ist weder jammern noch anklagen wer
mich kennt weiß dass ich wieder das eine
noch das andere tue und der weg aus der
diktatur aus rein in die demokratische
gesellschaft war und ist für mich
alternativlos aber wenn man selbst nicht
teil einer so tief greifenden
gesellschaftlichen transformation ist
hat man ganz andere alltagssorgen und
die prägen daneben auch das verständnis
um arbeit zu verstehen und zu lernen
muss strukturwandel strukturbruch
transformationen mit seinen
gesellschaftlichen auswirkungen stärker
noch in den fokus rücken eine säule des
zukunftszentrum soll diese gigantische
aufgabe übernehmen und diese
transformations- forschung muss im
ständige auseinandersetzung mit der
gesellschaft stattfinden an einem ort wo
veränderung auf veränderungen trifft und
wo geballte bevölkerungs meinung auf
wissenschaft trifft meine damen und
herren die für hertha muss der prozess
und war es auch in den osteuropäischen
nachbarländern gewesen sein die
entwicklung ostdeutschlands muss deshalb
auch immer im kontext mit der
entwicklung in osteuropa gesehen wird
ivan krastev schreibt immer wieder sehr
deutlich und sehr deutlich darüber warum
regionen oder nationen die gezwungen
werden oder die sich auch selber dazu
entscheiden andere gesellschaftliche
system anzunehmen zu imitieren nicht
glücklich werden sein zitat das leben
des imitators wird zunehmend von
gefühlen der unzulänglichkeit
minderwertigkeit abhängigkeit und das
verlust der eigenen identität beherrscht
es lohnt sich übrigens diese aufsätze in
gänze zu lesen denn wenn er auch
eigentlich über die osteuropäischen
staaten schreibt beschreibt er ein
problem das wir alle gemeinsam auch in
deutschland haben in dem prozess den
willy brandt beschrieben hat mit es
wächst zusammen was zusammen gehört aber
es wächst macht den satz wir wollen kein
imitat des westens sein den höre ich und
viele von uns seit über zwei jahrzehnten
auch in ostdeutschland und das müssen
wir ernst nehmen deshalb brauchen wir
den dialog mit einer gesellschaftlicher
dialog zwischen bürgerinnen und bürgern
unterschiedlicher regionen zwischen
generationen debatte nord und
begegnungszentrums das soll die zweite
säule des zukunftszentrum sein wir
brauchen in unserer zeit mit ihren
großen globalen neuen herausforderungen
keine fragmentierung der gesellschaft
sondern wir brauchen zusammenhalt
einander verstehen im besten falle
verständnis füreinander und die aktive
entscheidung dafür die herausforderung
gemeinsam anzugehen und was wäre dialog
ohne kultur deshalb steht über der
dritten säule des zukunftszentrum das
wort kulturzentrum wer eine ahnung davon
bekommen will von welcher idee wir uns
dabei leiten lassen haben sollte sich
das solidarisch zentrum in danzig
ansehen ständige ausstellung und
temporäre kulturelle bildung
künstlerische auseinandersetzung mit
phänomenen der gesellschaftlichen
transformation würdigung
gesellschaftlicher und individueller
lebensleistung austausch über die
geschichtliche entwicklung bis ins heute
und ideenentwicklung für das morgen
wanderausstellungen die republik das ist
nur eine unvollständige und kurze
beschreibung und trotz der
unterschiedlichen entwicklungen im neuen
größeren europa haben wir über die jahre
ein gutes ein neues europa ein stärkeres
europa aufgebaut das sich in krisen
gegenseitig stützt und wir erleben seit
dem überfall russlands auf die ukraine
wie stark dieses neue europa trotz der
unterschiedlichkeiten ist und wir stehen
alle vor großen herausforderungen die
nächsten transformationsprozesse stehen
ins haus energie ist dabei ein großes
thema die auswirkungen auf die
automobilindustrie betreffen alle
regionen europas mit ihren
arbeitsplätzen
und deshalb lassen sie uns gute ideen
für ein gutes gemeinsames morgen
entwickeln ein dank noch zum schluss an
alle die in der kommission und dem
zukunftszentrum mitgearbeitet haben als
teil beider gruppen weiß ich wie
arbeitsaufwendig und intensiv der
prozess war etwas und eine
entschuldigung an die cdu/csu-fraktion
ich will es hier auch sagen sie sind als
koalitionspartner der letzten legislatur
gleichsam mit geburtshelfer dieses
zentrum ist mein versorgen das ich hab
sie einfach zu spät eingebunden dann
hätte es auch ein gemeinsamer antrag
sein können ich würde mich aber freuen
wenn wir den prozess jetzt weiter
gemeinsam alle gehen hier wenn er im
plenum und auch im ausschuss beraten
vielen dank in einem antrag den katrin
budde hier erwähnt das ist der antrag
der ampel fraktionen aber da die idee
dieses zukunft sie zentrums jahr aus
einer regierungskommission aus der
letzten legislatur stammte und die union
daran mitgewirkt hat deswegen hier
nochmal ja die verbindenden worte von
katrin budde zu ende
zum ende ihrer rede so jonas gasfelds
der nächste für die cdu/csu-fraktion
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
kollegin ute wir bedanken uns gleich am
anfang für das statement am schluss weil
wir uns die einbindung natürlich
gewünscht hätten weil es ein gemeinsames
projekt ist es ist ein gemeinsames
projekt der vergangenen bundesregierung
was es jetzt gilt in die zukunft
fortzuführen und ich glaube es ist auch
ein gemeinsames projekt des ost und west
miteinander verbindet genauso wie sieht
es da gestellt haben weil es ein projekt
ist wo es einfach um vertrauen geht mein
mein wahlkreis coburg kronach
geroldsgrün liegt im norden bayerns
direkt an der ehemaligen innerdeutschen
grenze
wir sind also ich bin jetzt ein kind der
wiedervereinigung in anführungszeichen
ich kann mich an die trennung nur als
kleinkinder erinnern aber ich habe den
einigungsprozess erlebt und zwar genau
mit dem blickwinkel der uns in der
grenzregion jeden tag aufs neue
beschäftigt hat weil wir erlebt haben
wie die menschen in ostdeutschland
arbeitslos geworden sind weil wir erlebt
haben wie demographie eine region
beeinflusst zwar wir erlebt haben dass
es auch auswirkungen auf das nördliche
bayern hatte weil wir erlebt haben dass
grenzen weggefallen sind und dass
freundschaften entstanden sind auf
beiden seiten der grenze ich war am
vergangenen sonntag beim oberfränkischen
bezirksschützentag der hat es das erste
mal stattgefunden nicht in nordbayern
sondern in südthüringen und zwar in
sonnenberg unter dem stichwort schützen
überwinden grenzen war eine tolle
veranstaltung die sich in einer
tradition wieder gefunden hat die wir
auf fränkischer seite ein paar jahre
vorher angefangen haben nämlich dass wir
den tag der franken auch zum ersten mal
in thüringen veranstaltet haben vor dem
bewusstsein dass franken nicht an den
bayerischen landesgrenzen endet sondern
dass es eben auch einen fränkischen teil
thüringens gibt das ist genau das
das ist genau das was uns in der
grenzregion ausmacht dass man
zusammenarbeitet dass man zusammenlebt
und dass man auch gemeinsam themen setzt
und ich glaube im zukunftszentrum ist
auch sowas möglich
weil der titel an sich ich muss ehrlich
zugeben als ich ihn das erste mal gehört
habe habe ich gedacht er ist ein sehr
sehr starker titel
passt weil er beschreibt nämlich genau
das worauf es ankommt eine unglaublich
transformationsprozess eine
zukunftsperspektive und eine deutsche
einheit die zugleich europäische einheit
ist und das muss unser anspruch für die
zukunft sein gehen wir jetzt auch
weiterführen
als am 11 april die unterzeichner des
briefes mehr die europäische dimension
beim zukunft sensoren für europäische
transformationen deutsche einheit in den
blickwinkel und im mittelpunkt zu
stellen
unterzeichnet haben hatten sie in vielen
punkten recht weil wir sehen gerade dass
das was wir in deutschland auf dass wir
so stolz sein können im sinne einer
demokratisierung im sinne einer einheit
die entstanden ist im sinne einer
freiheit auch rückabgewickelt werden
kann freiheit ist nicht ein weg der in
eine richtung geht freiheit kann sich
auch umkehren wenn jemand vor 15 jahren
am roten platz in moskau mit einem still
gestanden wäre und demonstriert hätte
stünde er da den ganzen tag heute steht
er da keine fünf minuten
russischen parlament wird offen über die
wiedereinführung der todesstrafe
diskutiert
keiner von uns hätte gedacht dass ein
land seinen nachbarn über feld und
deswegen ist diese europäische dimension
so zentral und auch so wichtig und
und deswegen glaube ich dass es in dem
fall eben genau nicht darum geht dass
wir eine tribut pflichtige provinz
brüssel sind wie das die afg gerade
formuliert hat sondern dass es darum
geht dass wir europa als einheit denken
dass wir europa als einheit sehen
die für die demokratie auf steht die für
die freiheit eintritt und genau das
können wir im zukunftszentrum
formulieren indem wir die
zivilgesellschaft einbinden in dem wir
menschen in beiden teilen deutschlands
miteinander verbinden indem wir menschen
in ganz europa in den mittelpunkt setzen
indem wird demokratie starten weil das
das zentrale allen unseres gemeinwesens
ist
die beiden kolleginnen und kollegen wir
gehen den weg mit ihnen gemeinsam
gefreut auf die zusammenarbeit und wir
freuen uns darauf dass wir die
perspektive des zukunfts zentrums ein
bisschen erweitern und ich glaube das
ist unser gemeinsamer anspruch vielen
dank
so lars geisler war das für die
cdu/csu-fraktion und ihm folgt jetzt
hier
friedhelm boginski für die fdp fraktion
auch sagt er letztlich er in dieser
aussprache er kommt übrigens aus
brandenburg aus brandenburg bewirbt sich
die stadt frankfurt oder beispielsweise
als standort für das zukunftszentrum
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wenn wir nach mehr als 30 jahren über
die deutsche einheit sprechen klingt das
manchmal so als die wiedervereinigung
nach einem bestimmten zeitraum erreicht
wäre oder erreicht sein muss aber dem
ist nicht so sondern die einheit ist das
ziel eines prozesses der in der
friedlichen revolution
millionen menschen im ostteil der
republik begonnen wurde und am dritten
oktober 1990 ein zwischenziel erreichte
die staatliche einheit ein tag der
emotionen ein tag der freude der
überwindung der sed-diktatur mit seinen
unterdrückungsapparat aber es war auch
ein tag der vielen vielen individuellen
hoffnungen wünsche für eine bessere
zukunft und dann prallten die menschen
mit ihren wünschen und vorbereitet auf
die wettbewerbsorientierte
marktwirtschaft als ehemaliger
bürgermeister der brandenburgischen
kreisstadt etwas weiter habe ich die
auswirkungen der einheit selbst erlebt
eine stadt die rund 15.000 arbeitsplätze
und große betriebe verloren hat eine
stadt die von 53.000 einwohner auf
38.000 schrumpfte weil gut ausgebildete
junge frauen junge menschen insgesamt
die stadt verließen eine stadt die
zeitweise und perspektivlosigkeit
abrutschte und rechtsextremistische
gewalttaten zu beklagen hatte die
menschen im östlichen teil der republik
mussten sich den schmerzhaften
entwicklungen und umbrüchen stellen
eberswalde hatte auch bildung kultur
und zivilgesellschaft gesetzt und jeden
einzelnen menschen der sich weiter
entwickeln wollte und konnte
bildung kultur und zivilgesellschaft ist
das grundkonzept wenn wir heute über das
zukunftszentrum für deutsche einheit und
europäische transformation sprechen die
schaffung
dieses zentrums ist ausdruck des willens
die gesellschaftlichen endlich und vor
während und nach dem system umbrechen
besser zu verstehen und praxis
orientierte lehren daraus ziehen was
können wir gemeinsam in deutschland
besser machen aber gleichzeitig auch
darauf achten wie es unseren mittel
osteuropäischen nachbarn in der
transformation ergangen ist und wie wir
mit gegenseitigen verständnis die
europäische freiheitliche demokratische
zukunft gestalten können ein schlüssel
dabei ist die anerkennung und
wertschätzung jedes einzelnen menschen
und seiner biografie aber auch das
vertrauen darauf mit bildung kultur und
einer starken zivilgesellschaft und mit
den erfahrungen der vergangenheit die
zukunft erfolgreich zu gestalten und
jetzt der letzte satz mit dem
zukunftszentrum für deutschland einheit
und europäische transformation schauen
wir hierfür die grundlage herzlichen
dank
damit schließt sich die aussprache und
wir kommen zur abstimmung
tagesordnungspunkt 4 a hier kommt die
anzahl der fraktionen spd bündnis 90/die
grünen und fdp auf drucksache 1857 mit
dem titel ein zukunfts zentrum für
europäisch transformation und deutsche
einheit schaffen die fraktion spd
bündnis 90 die grünen fdp wünschen
abstimmung in der sache die fraktion cdu
csu würden überweisungen an den
ausschuss für kultur und medien und bin
ich gespannt der stimmen das ständige
übung zuerst antrag auf ausweisung ab
ich frage deshalb wer stimmt für die
beantragte autos überweisen
das sind
ja
das sind die oppositionsfraktion cdu csu
fdp und die linke wer stimmt dagegen das
sind die werte der regierungskoalition
damit ist der überweisung des antrags
abgelehnt wir kommen da als abstimmung
über den antrag auf drucksache
1857 in der sache wer stimmt für diesen
antrag
der stimmt dagegen
enthält sich dann ist diese antwort bei
enthaltung der fraktion raf die und
linke mit den sternen fraktionen des
hauses angenommen